of all the species on earth humans have
left the biggest mine if we suddenly
disappeared what would happen to our
highways cities rivers our greatest
monuments
Friday June 13th human history stops
the moment we disappear the world begins
to change power is generated by more
than 50,000 power plants around the
globe to keep the fires burn many
require a steady supply of coal but
today the deliveries have stopped the
worldwide loss of electricity also
affects nuclear power plants automated
systems detect that the electrical grid
is failing they shut off the reactors
the dark ages are back all over the
world pests are getting hungry if they
don't find food and water soon they'll
die they're not the only animals
affected the massive power failure
reaches the world zoos and safari parks
without electric fences to keep them in
Predators are free to explore
day ten driven by instinct dogs from the
city are roaming the countryside looking
for food every dairy cow has died they
could not survive without their human
caretakers but in the wide-open spaces
of Western North America free-range
cattle are thriving
nuclear disaster without a constant
supply of cold water spent nuclear
industry as board the treating tanks dry
a deadly mix of radioactive particles
spews from the plant within a matter of
weeks giant plumes of radioactive smoke
are spreading across the northern
hemisphere large animals are fleeing
Ares where plants have died from
radiation poisoning but small creatures
have a harder time escaping the
poisonous food ten months since humans
disappeared poisoned by radiation
evergreens have lost their ability to
grow new shoots and branches but farther
from the power plants spring is a time
to repair the damage we've left behind
rain washes radioactive dust and debris
from leaves and bark the poisonous atoms
are being driven underground there's
still a threat to anything that lives in
the earth but our radioactive
fingerprint is disappearing a population
explosion begins as animals take over
the empty spaces this new world is
filled with new opportunities
you